thanks for coming out today so our
biomechatronics lab is dedicated to
improving Quality of Life by enhancing
the functionality of artificial hands in
human machine systems and we really
think a lot about touch so you'll see
that throughout this talk we study human
grasp and manipulation as inspiration we
design tactile sensors and tactile
perception algorithms and then we
leverage sensorized systems to advance
robotic grasp and manipulation
um but I'm going to put in a Shameless
plug right now because tis the season
for faculty hiring so if you're on the
market please consider checking out all
UCLA all of our engineering departments
are hiring we also have some school-wide
EDI initiative
faculty positions as well we're also
currently in the process of
Designing and building a 10 000 square
foot collaborative robotic space and
we'll have six pis who are all giving up
their their current labs and moving into
this shared space so we're really
excited about that and about 35 percent
of that space is going to be communal
and open to anyone in the engineering
school who wants to do something with
our fabrication facilities our motion
capture facilities the robots that we'll
have so we're really excited about this
in the next couple of years
um I don't have time to talk about what
we do on the human side of things but
just to give you a little flavor we have
looked at grip responses to unexpected
perturbations multi-digit coordination
object handovers some of you may know
Eric Tang who joined my lab at Arizona
State back when he was a freshman and he
did his PhD here we also have been
recently getting into eye gaze tracking
and using that to infer human intent for
activities daily living and we've also
been doing some work on work on a human
haptic search and retrieval and to
inspire some of the work that you'll see
later on the robotic version
but today what I'm going to be talking
about is really the sense of touch and I
would argue that modern artificial hands
um you know may be able to have fast
movements and mimic many of the complex
movements of the human hand but I have a
little snippet of a video here to kind
of start and bookend my talk about the
importance of touch
correspondent had much of his left arm
amputated last year after an accident
while on a reporting trip for the
NewsHour he has since been exploring
leaps forward for modern Prosthetics and
feel free to adjust it as needed okay
a hand without a sense of touch isn't
really a hand at all it's more like a
pair of pliers
watch blindfolded hand amputee Igor
spedic try to pick up some blocks using
a prosthetic without a sense of touch
it's not very productive that was no
sensation no sensation and so you were
just going blind literally glowing blood
now watch what happens when the sensory
perception is turned on
it's like night and day but then when I
grab it
if I grab it just right I feel all three
fingers if I grab a right or two fingers
then I know I have it and then I'll move
over and drop it
is it your Phantom hand that you're
feeling it in or is
oh don't feel pain them to me when I
grab a block
to me it doesn't it feels like my hand
feels like something between my two
fingers that's vibrating for Igor who
lost his hand at an industrial accident
four years ago something powered by a
battery and made of plastic metal and
silicon can become his hand
all right so I'm gonna have little
Snippets of things throughout this talk
that'll kind of be formatted like this
where it just gives you some insights
into how our lab thinks about touch and
the first one is that touch is useful
and I saw on your robotic seminar series
um itinerary from this past quarter that
you've had previous speakers on touch so
hopefully I'm preaching to the choir
here but a touch is useful whether it's
for machines that are working within the
human body are intimately attached to
the human body are working close to the
human body whether at home or on the
manufacturing line or in places where
you do not want to put humans in order
to keep them safe so search and rescue
handling of dangerous materials whether
that's decommissioning nuclear sites or
looking for explosive ordinance or in
very extreme environments like
underwater or in space
and for all of these applications you
know of course we're going to use all of
the sensory data that we have available
to us especially Vision which can be
used for planning and also
reactive control however there are many
times when you may not have a direct
line of sight or the hand itself is
including the object that you're trying
to manipulate you're in the dark you're
behind obstacles or inside containers or
you may have Vision but it's it's
limited so maybe you're in a wildfire so
there's smoke or you're in turbid water
and of course if you're going to work
with more complicated materials or
objects that are not strictly rigid and
for which you may not have a model
there are times when you can use Vision
to look at the pose or configuration of
the item but from just a straight rope
you cannot tell what is the tension in
that rope and that's something where
complementary senses like tactile
sensing and proprioception become
especially useful
so also manipulating deformable thin
sheets or even deformable bulk materials
and maybe someday even bulk but animate
objects that have their own their own
agency as well and then of course I had
to throw an in-hand manipulation one of
the grand challenges for a robot grasp
and manipulation
so touch is multifaceted and I'm going
to show you a variety of different
tactile sensors that we work with we're
agnostic when it comes to tactile
sensing I don't think there's any one
piece of technology that that rules them
all it really is very application
dependent and I don't think that any of
our artificial tactical centers come
close to the beauty of human biological
mechanoreceptors which have very
specialized mechanoreceptors spread out
in clever ways so for example you might
have super a superficial layer of
Miser corpuscles or Merkel discs or you
have other petini and petini-like and
raffini mechanoreceptors in the Deep
part of the skin and within each of
these layers you also have
mechanoreceptors that respond to
transients so things like vibrations and
fast changes but also to slow static
sustained strain
and so this is you know what what I
think a lot of people designing tactile
sensors aspire to
um I don't think we're there yet but
we're we're working on pieces of it so
I'm going to begin with some of the the
low-cost DIY types of sensors Piezo
resistive fabric sensors are one type
where you have layers and of course the
material itself is responsive to a
strain we also have a barometer based
sensors so taking barometers that you
can get for your cell phones but
embedding them in elastomer that you
cure within a vacuum and now when you
press on the vacuum you can measure some
change it's a little bit crude but you
can measure some forces being applied to
that bulk material within which the
barometers are embedded
uh if you have a little bit more access
to specialized equipment you can do
microfluidic tactile sensor skins this
is a collaboration with Jonathan Posner
we were next to our office Neighbors at
Arizona State and now he's up at
University of Washington and his team
will make sensors and we characterize
them and adapt them to robots in our lab
but about a decade ago we started at
Arizona State just taking liquid metal
and using them as both wire paths and
sensing tackles so where you see these
paths crossing over crossing over one
another they're not intersecting they're
actually crossing over and where they
pass over one another you get a little
capacitive taxal or a tactile analog to
the pixel but when we uh and this
actually only senses normal force
because we're just squeezing it along
this direction but if you want to design
something for a Shear Force we we
switched from the capacitive approach to
a resistive approach so just think of
these as liquid metal strain gauges that
you can put in the serpentine Direction
which now has a direction of greatest
sensitivity or the circular patterns
that allow you to measure force in
normal force in equally in all
directions and so if you use both of
these patterns you can use pairs of
these Serpentine
um strain gauges to measure Shear
strength so if you put your finger down
on a the armrest near you and you shift
your finger left to right and think
about where you're feeling the strain in
the skin
you probably feel something near your
nail bed and that's exactly what we did
here is we put pairs of these along
where a nail bed would be so that you
can measure Shear in that direction and
then you can imagine if you put another
pair here you'll get sheer in that
orthogonal direction but the nice thing
is if you can sense from way back here
where there's not even contact with an
object it leaves all of this real estate
open for the normal taxes that where you
expect direct contact
so that was the idea behind that design
and more recently we've taken that
design made it a little bit bigger and
have been working on making it useful
underwater under pressure so we had to
build a lab bench set up to pressurize
the system apply stimuli and and
calibrate
we also like many groups have been
working with camera based elastomeric
tactile sensors these are all the rage
because all the computer vision
algorithms can be directly applied to
the tactile data and you can look at the
tactile flow this is a collaboration
with Ted Adelson at MIT who created the
gel site
but the idea is that you have a camera
embedded within the finger that looks
out at the world through this um
elastomeric finger pad and if you put an
array of dots on the inside you can
track the optical flow and then for
local geometry forces and torques and
some more recent papers coming out of
different groups have now started
playing with the transparency of the
Skin So if you make the skin more
transparent or even
have a way to go from transparent to
opaque you can use this same setup for
proximity sensing so that's a really
exciting development
and of course if you want to go the open
source route Facebook or meta now has a
recipe for the digit which we have
recently been customizing by putting
markers on the inside and adapting them
to different sensors in our robots in
our lab
but the sensor you're going to see
throughout most of the rest of the talk
is the biotech and that's because I
worked on it when I was a postdoc with
Jerry Loeb at USC it was funded by the
DARPA revolutionizing Prosthetics
program at the time so it was bio
inspired and intended to go on
prosthetic hands and so it has a rigid
core like the bone in your finger an
elastomeric skin that's inflated away
from the core by a conductive fluid on
the surface of the coral have an image
later in the talk but there is an array
of electrodes and if you track how the
skin moves toward and bulges away from
that that array of impedance electrodes
you can infer what's happening to the
overall shape of the finger pad and
basically for free if you tap into this
fluid volume with an off-the-shelf
pressure sensor that's housed safely in
the core you can now have a hydrophone
that you can sample slowly to measure a
crude measurement of overall fingertip
force or a sample up to 2200 Hertz and
pick up vibrations and vibrations
associated with different textures for
example
there's also a thermistor in the front
of the fingertip and you can use the
rate of heat conduction away from the
finger to infer material properties
so
it can be overkill for many of the
applications that you might be
interested in but because we already had
a bunch of them we we use them on all of
our systems and then we did ablation
studies after the fact to test what
would happen if you didn't have
different types of modalities how would
the performance of your algorithm go
down
okay so I showed you hardware for
transducing mechanical stimuli or in
some cases thermal stimuli but those are
still just an array of numbers that are
flowing in real time so how do we make
sense as humans or even robots
make sense of the data to make decisions
well I would say that touch is
abstraction because you need to take
those numbers and somehow abstract them
to Concepts that we can make sense of or
maybe in the case of you know
reinforcement learning maybe they're
things that we don't fully understand
but that an algorithm can use to improve
its performance so by abstracted
features I'm talking about things like
texture hardness Global shape local
shape and this classic paper from
Lederman and klasky in the 80s
basically defined what's called an
exploratory procedure these are
movements that are specifically taken to
extract certain types of information
so if I ask you what is the roughness of
the seat that you're sitting in now
you should be imagining what you do to
to answer that question and you're
likely to rub your finger against the
seat because that is a very typical
exploratory procedure when you are
seeking information about texture just
as squeezing gives you information about
hardness or hefting something against
gravity gives you information about
weight so what we did a little close to
a decade ago was We performed
exploratory procedures with a sensorized
robot
and we looked at edges Edge orientation
with respect to the body local features
like bumps pits of different sizes and
shapes and what we were after was a way
for the robot to classify or infer
the features that it was sensing so it
could decide what it wanted to do next
so just as you reach into your pocket
and you're able to find the power button
on your cell phone that's something that
we wanted to give you know a robot the
ability to do without Vision to just
feel and know okay I'm feeling an edge
and I can follow that edge so that was
our first foray into machine learning we
were using things like support Vector
machines back in the day now we use
things like convolutional neural
networks this is more recent work on the
tactile perception of directionality and
by directionality I mean you're holding
an object and either someone is taking
it from you or you're interacting with
the environment and you can feel through
the object some forces on your fingertip
what is the direction of that for us
that's that's what this algorithm will
tell you and so instead of moving an
object with respect to the fingertips we
just reversed it for all of our data
collection to move the fingertips
relative to the objects and you'll see
as we do this that you can actually see
the the finger pad changing shape
and so we do this thousands of times
collect a bunch of training data and
this is the finger core the biotech core
without the skin so you can see this
array of electrodes we roughly know the
location of these and we only have 19 of
them and so in order to apply computer
vision type approaches we use
interpolation to create a manifold and
what's on the z-axis here is the change
in electrode impedance so when that
change increases and goes positive we
know that the skin is getting compressed
toward the core of the finger if it goes
negative we know the Skin's bulging away
and then we can turn that into a
grayscale image where the intensity
refers to the change in impedance over
that particular region of the finger pad
and then of course if you do that for a
bunch of the different directions you
can see that there are patterns here and
so our convolutional neural networks are
able to figure that out
so this is an example of the real time
playing of the policy or the the model
that's learned
so purposely we had the robot grasp the
object but only release when it was the
appropriate context which is when
someone's pulling the object away from
the robot when the line points away from
the Palm is when the robot will release
and the sensitivity of this is something
that that you could adjust for your
application this is showing interactions
with the environment so as the upward
relative upward movement of the glass is
sensed when the object's being placed
again without Vision the robot can
respond appropriately to release the
glass
but one of the things that we've been
working on most recently that's I think
kind of fun and has been surprising in
terms of the things that we've been
discovering is putting tactile sensors
in granular media because you've seen
robots that are digging through walking
across running across granular media but
they don't typically have tactile
sensors and we were funded by the Office
of Naval Research to look for buried
objects that might be fragile or you may
not want to interact with them directly
or do it very carefully and so one of
the things that that we thought was
going to be a liability and really
annoying is the fact that media granular
media the particles can act like fluids
or solids depending on how they're
packed and how you're intruding upon
them so if you're intruding and dragging
your finger through there will be some
particles ahead of you that that freely
move kind of like a liquid but at some
point if that wedge of particles that's
moving ahead we call it the the soil
failure wedge in the literature if that
wedge tip hits something that's buried
what is created is this chain of
particles a force chain that will now
push back on your finger even even
though you're not directly touching the
object and what we thought was that well
this kind of gives our tactile sensor in
granular media
proximity sensor-like capabilities so
there's a kind of nice parallel between
using tactile sensors in granular media
with jamming to traditional slam
approaches we're using a proximity
sensor to map something out
and that was our approach here so what
you're going to see is in this video the
little white dots are the you know the
pixels that are changing and there's
going to be a little
um
soil failure region here that moves
ahead of the finger and up in the upper
right hand corner just know that those
are two measurements of you know roughly
the force or the torque on the fingertip
and you'll see that there will be an
increase in the force on the fingertip
when that soil failure wedge hits this
buried object but the fingertip has not
yet reached it
so this is the soil moving ahead of the
finger
foreign
there we start to see an increase
because of that granular media jamming
so if you know or can characterize the
properties of the granular media you can
use that to reduce uncertainty in the
map that you're building of the buried
object so that's what we did we're
leveraging this transition from free
movement to some some jamming statement
we have a different paper in the works
that gets more into greatly media
jamming with different types of
materials but for this project we used a
heterogeneous sand mixture with pebbles
and things and this shows how we can
turn this data along with exploratory
movements into Bayesian Hilbert map that
tells us about occupancy
so you'll see one exploratory movement
from that hand and that's what we infer
from that one movement then we have a
second one
and with each increase or update in this
map you can think about how to plan the
next exploratory movement to reduce the
uncertainty in your current map and
after about I think seven movements here
we're able to have a decent
occupancy map of the object that we then
uncovered to show where it was
but of course touch is very expensive so
if if you anyone here collects tactile
sensor data you'll know it takes a lot
of effort to get the robot Hardware up
and running to program it to collect
thousands of Trials of data sometimes
the sensors can break or wear out the
bio attack that I showed has
fingerprints on the skin to amplify
vibration and you will wear out the
fingerprints that's a consumable that
you have to replace so touch is very
expensive I can't go cannot go online
and download millions of images to
perform data mining with I actually have
to collect the data so I have a couple
examples here
of projects where we wanted to
demonstrate the ability for the robot to
learn a hard to code skill and in this
case we're closing a Ziploc bag but you
can think of it as a functional Contour
following task where both the tactile
sensor and the object being manipulated
is deformable and we don't have good
models for them I think now there's a
better model of the biotech out there
but it's still not an analytical model
it's um so yes with the biotech model we
can model the deformation of the finger
Pad but we don't really have a good
model for the electrical
phenomenon happening within the pad with
respect to the impedance electrodes so
for that you can bridge that Gap with
actual tactile sensor data and neural
networks and that's what the literature
has done so here we have set up a camera
to track the motion of the the fingers
relative to this zipper we do that to
automate the learning process but once
the policy is learned we can turn that
off and it'll work so this is just
demonstrating what would happen if you
tried naive linear trajectories relative
to a linear zipper that you may be able
to view with computer vision but at some
point the finger will probably fall off
of the zipper unless you make corrective
movements because of the way that the
the bag will
deform
so what we did this was our first foray
into reinforcement learning so we took a
very simple primitive approach and we
said okay what are the different states
and Rewards well we'll have three states
low Center and High and ideally you keep
that sweet spot of the finger pad
aligned with the zipper because
otherwise you're going to fall off the
zipper right either too low or too high
and let's reward for being in the center
and then this asymmetric set of actions
came about after some pilot studies but
these are the five actions that the
robot can take after it senses its state
and and whether it got a reward or not
of course there's exploration and
exploitation happening at the same time
so what we did in this project was to
show how contextual multi-armed Bandits
could be used to learn expected rewards
throughout exploration in an online way
so you have the fingertip moving we have
up here in the upper left how the
impedance electrode values change
whether they're getting squished towards
the core or bulging away from the core
we have down here a classification of
the state and then some reward or zero
that goes along with that
and once we learn a policy for this we
demonstrated the learn policy on other
types of bags that were not used during
training and these happen to be more
flexible you may have recognized the
McMaster Car bags in the in the previous
video These are more
soft flexible ones that you'd find in
the kitchen
and we also tried it with different
loading conditions which we had not
trained upon
and there's a lot of we had to speed it
up because of the motion planning delay
that wasn't something that the student
was very motivated to to fix and and
find with me that was not the point of
the study so I was happy with this
um the other hard to code task that we
recently completed with a little more
sophisticated reinforcement learning was
turning a page in a notebook which
sounds very simple for us but it's
surprising how related your action is to
the tactile stimuli that you get and we
can actually pick up on very subtle
changes in what's going on at the
fingertip even with just grabbing a
piece of paper which I'll show you in a
couple slides so we had a Canova arm
biotech sensors we had binders here with
Pages we threw on motion capture markers
because our reward function took into
account how the multimodal tackle sensor
data diverge from what we call a
functional set of data as well as a
binder movement
so if the binder moved too much then we
would call that an aggressive movement
so
I'll show you here these different three
different classes of page flipping
behaviors that we use to demonstrate
reinforcement learning in a model-free
way using tactile sensor data and we had
to make up some kind of Ideal functional
ideal so we we decided that it would be
this one where it's a semicircular
trajectory just imagine the fingertips
kind of following a half circle
and then we had other undesired page
flipping behaviors one is with page
warping and snapping so you can imagine
if if there's a radius for that
semicircular trajectory and you decrease
that radius now you're going to force
the page to warp and then when it gets
turned over here you'll see it snap and
we can actually pick up the transient of
the snap with our biotech and then if
you imagine that now that radius is
increased now you're pulling too much
and too hard and you'll get the binder
movement that we penalized for in our
reward function
of all these three cases I think the one
that's most interesting to watch is the
page warping and snapping
there's the warping there's the snap
and so at the end of the day the pages
always get turned but they're turned in
different ways and in this example we
were trying to show that the tactile
sensory data changes in a different way
so don't bother yourselves with the
interest intricacies of the data but I
just wanted to show you that we have
different responses for the top finger
and the bottom finger they experience
different things within each of the
fingers depending on where you are on
the finger the electrodes experience
different things and then depending on
the page flipping behavior that you get
different responses so the aggressive
trajectories are shown in red you can
see these little spikes for the blue
with the snapping of the pages and we
were trying to get the robot to learn
you know even if starting with a
sub-optimal type of trajectory can it
learn to adjust its its motion roll out
according to tactile sensor data only to
get back to something that is more ideal
in our case
and so we were able to do that and not
only were we able to do that for a
nominal trajectory but then we showed
that we could adapt and learned nominal
trajectory to different contexts so if
you learned on small pages and and then
um we're told to adapt to a different
context like large Pages or vice versa
you would necessarily have to change the
radius of your trajectory and the robot
was able to do that using tactile sensor
data
so the left column is the the first
policy update and by the time we were
happy with the performance that's the
right column
so even starting with a sub-optimal
movement after a certain number of
policy updates using the tactile sensor
data we could get to something that we
considered to be ideal
all right so the next point I have just
a couple slides is that touch is
shareable
so if you can collect the tactile sensor
data you can send that to somebody
you could use it for the robot to make
its own semi-autonomous decisions but if
you have a haptic display then you can
send that to a remote operator of a
robot so this is me at ikra attempting
to buy manually control this setup to
manipulate this little block and I'm
doing it remotely and I'm really using
trying to use my visual feedback but at
times it was occluded so the touch
helped a little bit there but the point
is that if you can sense what's going on
at a remote robot location you can
convey that back and share it with
someone else
uh so this is the the video that I meant
to to uh bookend and pair with the one I
showed before again this is a follow-up
for Dustin Tyler's Lab at Case Western
Reserve University with whom we have a
new collaboration
Presswood lost his arm in a workplace
accident in 2012 and is also a
participant in Tyler's study
he too had surgery connecting his nerves
to sensors in the fingertips of a
sophisticated prosthetic limb basically
they've mapped where if they put this
electrical signal to this contact on the
nerve cuff then that makes me feel a pin
prick in my index finger but he doesn't
even have to wear it to get that feeling
the fact is attached to his arm is
actually kind of arbitrary we can put
the prosthesis anywhere in the world and
he would still feel like his hand
pressed wood is trying out the idea with
his prosthetic arm mounted across
Tyler's lab and so now we can extend his
capability we can essentially amplify
the person by taking that sense of
connection the sense of touch and
putting it on any machine any part of
the world and bring it back to your
nervous system and then I can connect it
to devices that can do far more than my
weak biologic system
all right so
this video and with the block stacking
task you think that you can notice that
it's it's a lot about functional tasks
um did I get the job done am I getting
the right type of feedback to
appropriately adjust my grasp and
manipulate the object but the last thing
I want to tell you about touch is
something that I've been thinking more
about more recently and that is touch is
connection
right so affective touch is a field
that's already existed it's only I'm
just beginning to to get into that area
along with Dustin Tyler and it's a
change for me in the way that I think
because I've always been thinking so
much in terms of did I did I get the
zipper closed did I turn the page and
all that but there are other aspects to
touch that are about the social
connection
whether you're trying to connect with a
little one or a big bigger loved one
right
um and you know because of covid and
social distancing the fact that we
weren't allowed to hug for a long time
even at the acre conference you had
little badges that were you know are you
okay to shake or you shake hands are you
okay to Elbow bump or you're just you
know you're not ready to to interact
that way so
um I think we're still moving through
this but even after the pandemic is over
there are going to be populations of
individuals who still for various
reasons maybe they are medically
vulnerable high risk for infection are
not going to be able to get back out
into the world and that's where having a
robot avatar for example can re- help
reconnect people to these community
activities so because of covet and
everything Cynthia gorney actually
interviewed many labs around the world
and Dustin and I were very lucky to be
included in this cover story on the
power of touch but it really focuses on
touch from a social perspective
so a little bit more about what we're
doing with Dustin he launched the human
fusions Institute which is aimed at
directly connecting human and robot
experiences using what they call Neural
reality to enable humans to be
physically in one place and
experientially in another ultimately to
enable embodiment
and I'm not saying that that you know
teleoperation telepresence tell
existence is anything new that has you
know tele existence was created I think
back in the 80s and in Japan
um this but I think there's a renewed
interest
and I think that the interest is
starting to go beyond teleoperation
from a functional perspective to
embodiment where it's about enhancing
not only the operators social experience
but the experience of the people that
that operator is interacting with and I
think there's a lot to be explored there
so we threw our hat into the a a avatar
X prize competition and we only had I
think six to nine months to put
something together so we went a totally
different way from the groups that you
may have viewed either in person or via
live stream at the finals about a week
ago
um the typical approach is to get very
large robotic arms have two of them so
you can do bimanual things Mount them to
a mobile base and have this gigantic
mobile manipulator and maybe have an
exact replica that an operator will
remotely wear and move and then the the
Avatar mimics we went a completely
opposite way because we we wanted to do
something that would really focus on the
operator's experience and so and also
safety so this is the stretch robot from
Hello robot it purposely has a very
small footprint it's very lightweight
it's meant to go in homes and be used by
individuals with impairment it does not
have a Serial linkage arm it has more of
a Gantry style arm
and we took off the passive suction cup
gripper style end effector and put on
this Tech this sensorized prosthetic
hand that Dustin already had access to
and then we took the the Intel real
sense you know the RGB D camera and we
slapped a zed mini camera right over the
top because we weren't going to do
anything automated we just wanted to
send binocular vision directly back to
the operator who is in Cleveland and so
the operator system had electric Electro
tactile haptic display and was wearing a
commercially available headset for audio
and visual feedback
and the goal was as usual for many tele
operation approaches immersion seamless
embodiment intuitive controls multimodal
feedback but again we were really
focused on what the operator would
experience so we spent a lot of time on
training the operator and you know even
just having the operator tell them to
close their eyes we engage them with the
remote system and then we say open your
eyes welcome you're in Los Angeles now
and having this training regime where
you know when someone is operating a
robot I think it's different than
someone embodying a robot where now you
need to think about Perry personal space
and etiquette I actually startled the
National Geographic
journalist when she was in Cleveland she
was operating the robot in our lab and I
thought I was being friendly and I
popped right in front of the camera and
I weaved and said hi Cynthia and it
startled her because she didn't have the
field of view she wasn't expecting me to
do that and you know you would never do
that to someone who was right in front
of you you'll just jump out in front of
them but I had not thought of her as in
that way and so I think both from the
operator's perspective and the other
interactors there are some social
etiquette things that that still need to
be worked out if we're really going to
head towards embodiment as opposed to
just functional teleoperation so we
focused on the two things that we
thought were most important for the
operator which are the ability to
have binocular vision and control where
you're looking
as if in an egocentric way and then
having some tactile sensation on the
hand these are not the greatest tactile
sensors but they are cheap and already
built into the hand and it's surprising
I was surprised when I tried the system
that even a very simplistic approach to
Heckle sensing when you have visual
visual tactile synchrony it's actually a
very powerful combination
so I have one more funny anecdote you
might enjoy which is we were setting up
this demo for a VIP visitor and I wanted
to make sure I tested it and when I
tested it and they I closed my eyes they
said you're engaged I open my eyes I saw
myself from behind
and it was really weird it was like kind
of like the Hermione Granger experience
if you know Harry Potter where you see
yourself from this third person
perspective in a way that you shouldn't
normally and so um after that I I told
my student please make sure that you
know the VIP faces that way and the
robot faces that way because it's
already difficult for someone who's not
used to this technology to interact with
it let alone have like kind of a meta
experience on top of that
um but and then on the local operator
side what we call Cleveland
this is the headset we used a hand
tracking built into the headset again we
were going for something easily scalable
low-cost very Deployable so we didn't
have motion capture systems we didn't
have a fancy seven degree of Freedom
Arms to capture all the movements we
threw a white glove on for contrast and
and um track the hand that way
and yeah we were pleased we made it to
semifinals and I have established a
productive collaboration
so the last thing I want to leave you
with are just things that I I think are
unsolved challenges if you're looking
for for new things to inspire you
um things that that I think are exciting
directions not only uh in robotics
related to touch but also what I think
is going to be a new field of social
physical human robot interactions right
we've had physical human robot
interactions social HRI but social and
physical
um I think is is up and coming
so I mentioned this a little earlier in
my talk but combining proximity and
tactile sensing I think is something
that is underexplored and there's a lot
to be learned there there were
previously other attempts to put cameras
in the palms of hands and things like
that so that as you're approaching an
object with your hand open you could
adjust your hand placement relatively
object then close the hand but I think
having proximity sensing wherever you
put tactile sensing would be really
exciting
also Sim to real for tactile sensing so
this goes back to the touch is expensive
part
unless you have a tactile sensor that
you for which you have a nice analytical
model it's really difficult to predict
the sensory effect of an action that you
take and there's this action perception
Loop right you perform an action to
perceive something once you've perceived
something you can determine your next
action and I think
um you know perceiving something and
then determining either the action that
got you there or the action that you
should take after is is difficult so if
we had Sim to real for tactile sensing
that might enable
more reinforcement learning to happen in
simulation and then directly transfer to
hardware
talking about social physical
interactions one good example is
huggybot which was created by Alexis
block she's a postdoc in my lab and she
had numerous PhD advisors one of whom
was Catherine kookenbecker and um you
know she created this before the
pandemic and um and you know received
some negative comments about it when she
first started and now now it's actually
finally being recognized as something
valuable now that the whole world has
endured the pandemic just the lack of
physical interaction between people I
think and that social connection that
you have just from a hug or you know a
congratulatory pat on the back or a
comforting stroke on the arm these are
all part of the social physical
interaction field
and uh an example I heard about recently
is a cafe in Japan that enables impaired
individuals to re-enter the workforce by
logging in from home and embodying this
Avatar that can serve you in a
restaurant and I think you know that has
both the functional and the the social
component to it what I did not put in
pictures on this slide is shown on the
bottom large area tactile sensing how do
we go from tactile sensors that are just
on fingertips maybe on Palms to
everywhere
and um you know once we start scaling up
that way are we going to need different
types of processing approaches so there
are some groups that have been working
on neuromorphic hardware for some time
but um they're starting to get a lot of
attention from funding agencies now for
event-based neuromorphic tactile sensing
so that you're not wasting your power
your your processing effort on sensing a
full body's worth of data when nothing's
happening you're only paying attention
to it when something interesting is
happening that will make you think about
it and maybe respond right
so I think all of my collaborators the
students that do all of the work and our
funding agencies and I'm thank you for
your attention and happy to take
questions
[Applause]
yeah
thanks for the really interesting talk
you've shown a lot of slides and videos
about humans with prosthetics recovering
their sense of touch through sensors I'm
curious how the interfacing between the
sensor device and human neural systems
actually work
if if you're going invasive one of the
older approaches and it's still used is
to grow directly to the somatosensory
cortex brain machine interfaces there
are some groups that want to leverage
all of the circuitry that is still
intact farther down the stream which is
why researchers like Dustin Tyler use
peripheral nerve stimulation and they
have cuff electrodes that that will have
different stimulation patterns and that
again is an art the bridge between the
tactile sensor numbers that are
streaming in and what you actually use
to stimulate is where the bioengineering
and and
the engineering choices have to be made
because
um I've I've given talks like this
before where people would say well why
would you ever want to convey to an
individual with limb loss the
orientation of an edge like of course
you wouldn't right why would I tell them
oh that you're touching an edge and by
the way it's 10 degrees from the long
axis of your finger I think that's
something that you might do for a
semi-autonomous robot but for someone
who has agency you might get more bang
for your buck by just streaming In The
Raw data maybe having as much of a
one-to-one mapping or some kind of
filtration from the the tactile sensor
that is not biological at all to some
set of patterns and and hopefully the
patient can learn that mapping and
everyone's gonna have to learn a
different mapping it's a different
embodiment and no one has the same
reaction when you stimulate them in the
same place it's very subject-specific I
see thank you
and and I don't think it's natural I
think that um you know a lot of people
say are you really restoring natural
sensation and I don't think my
collaborators claim that they are it's
just additional information that was
lost but now when you give them some
information about their physical
interaction it helps their performance
maybe it helps with their sense of
connection to someone that's what we're
after
however a question about this last
remark that you made about the
neuromorphic tactile sentencing tactile
sensing has not come into the picture
yes just if you can elaborate yeah well
I'm brand new to this too and I'm trying
I'm like trying to drink from the the
fire hose because
um my understanding is the event-based
neuromorphic approach has been applied
to Vision right
um and so there are groups I'm looking
forward to starting collaboration with
Kiara bartolozzi in Italy and um
and we want to try those techniques on
on tactile data and so there are what
I'm learning are hard neuromorphic
approaches and soft neuromorphic
approaches and I think for our lab and
the collaborations in in the short term
because we don't do any of that Hardware
design we're going to do the soft
neuromorphic approach where you collect
the data and then you you interblade and
assume you have way more samples than
you do and then what's currently over my
head but I want to learn are spiking
neural networks that's that's something
that my group has not done yet but we
would have to learn in order to apply
these neural board approaches
hi thanks for the talk I have a question
about a calibration for these tactile
Sensors how painful is it generally to
calibrate to tactile senses painful yeah
because especially with the the
handcrafted ones they're they're exactly
that they're handcrafted they're not
commercially available devices that you
could just send to the vendor and they
just run their hit the go and then send
you back a little calibration Matrix for
us because our tackle sensors you'll
notice are pretty much all deformable
everyone's a little bit different so
calibration means applying a known set
of stimuli recording the numbers that
come out of that and building some
usually non-linear model to link the two
see yeah and you usually have that
ground truth with you yes so it's
important well it depends on what you
care about so some people care about
actual numbers like what was was it
point one Newtons or was it point two
Newtons in that case you need to Mount
Your sensor to something with an actual
calibrated load cell beneath it like a
six degree of freedom load cell so you
can report those things if you don't do
not care about absolute magnitudes but
you care about relative changes then
that's really all that matters and
calibration is essentially
um you know baselining before any
contact and then having some known
stimuli and looking at the ranges of
changes and going back to the
neuromorphic approach maybe you have for
a greater intensity of magnitude or
greater change in like an impedance
electrode resistance value you have a
higher frequency of firing or something
depends on the the slow adapting or fast
adapting type of mechanoreceptor you're
trying to emulate
thank you
that's the calibration is the unsexy
stuff that students have to do and never
makes it into a publication
foreign
if not all right well thank you and
thanks again to the speaker and
turn off the mic
just a small question on the uh liquid
metal base capacitive sensor I think
that's the one on the top right so it
looks like um you're sorry I guess I'm
curious
in such design the wires would also be
basically sensors so do you have
thoughts on like shielding or how do you
deal with yeah we haven't had too much
uh problems with many problems with
interference in that sense I think
because
if you actually stretch and twist these
things the amount of change of
capacitance or resistance over the
tackle that you care about is much
smaller than what what you care about
when you actually have a stimulus so we
haven't had that trouble with this yet
you're talking about the the bits of um
like the bits of wire that are out here
possibly acting like an antenna
um yeah yeah I think if we were looking
at something that was really sensitive
that would probably be a problem but for
us looking at maybe 0.1 Newtons for very
light touch or in the case of the
underwater example 200 Newtons that's
not going to be an issue I see thank you
the thing that is an issue that everyone
glosses over but um since you're
interested the hardest part about this
is the bridge from the liquid metal wire
to the rigid wire that has to go to the
DAC board that is what rips out all the
time
so that's why this sensor actually has
no rigid virus shown because we've
played with it so much that they've
popped out but that interface if someone
can solve that liquid soft to rigid
transition
that that would be a game changer
I'd have my own troubles with those
stuff yeah I told a few of you
thanks
all right thank you again thank you
conclude